we want to introduce you to mint mobile
an affordable wireless plan that
operates online only
rocky spoke to the company to learn more
about its convenience and coverage
erin north welcome to the show hi how
are you
i'm good ready to talk about mint mobile
so let's just
get to it what is mint uh well mint's
really really easy to explain
mint is premium wireless sold
directly to the consumer so mint is
wireless like you know it today
just our our special sauce if you will
is that
we sell mint online and we sell mint
direct to the customer
which nobody else is really doing right
now which is exciting for us because
we've been a pioneer in the space
and it's been really really fun why does
premium wireless cost so little why is
how is it so affordable
right so mint is direct to consumer so
what we've done is we don't own
any stores and that was a decision we
made very on very early on right from
the start
and because we don't own stores what
we're able to do
is we're able to save a bunch of expense
when it comes to selling wireless
so rather than keeping that money as
profit we decided to
take that money and use it basically to
lower the price the consumer so with
mint
our entry level plan which is four gigs
of data is only
15 a month and then we ladder that up to
an unlimited plan which is only sold
at 30 a month so it's pretty incredible
value
wow and can we elaborate more on the
plans what what other plans do you guys
have
yeah so everything with mint um there's
a lot of things that come with every
plan so you get unlimited talk
you get unlimited texts which i think
everybody expects
you get to choose how much data you want
and that's what varies the price but you
also get
unlimited calling to mexico you get
unlimited calling to canada
mint offers 5g for free so if you have a
5g enabled device
you don't have to pay extra or go to
only a super expensive plan
to get 5g it's included in everything we
sell
so yeah it's really premium wireless is
meant to mean
it is everything you want wireless and
nothing you don't um
and it's just it's a great product a
great service at an incredible price
wow and how is the coverage here in las
vegas and southern nevada
oh i mean well i'm in southern
california and i make that drive so
i love i love vegas um we actually run
so mint runs exclusively on the t-mobile
network
so coverage nationwide is phenomenal um
t-mobile's got the largest most
expansive 5g network
so we're really excited to be on that
network and
i think everybody in vegas knows like
the reception there is
excellent the reception here in southern
california just as good and
love making that drive listening to
podcasts or
you know digital radio and you get great
coverage the whole way out and where can
people find more information about mint
mobile
so you can buy mint online at mobile.com
i'm sure people will google it but we're
also sold
in target and best buy so you can go to
either target best buy or mobile.com and
get us
thank you rocky visit mintmobile.com for
more information on their plans and all
they have to offer
las vegas now we'll be right